all right Grace
hi welcome back
it's good to be back
your first talk that you did with me was
a really interesting talk on borderline
personality disorder yeah it's been
several months since we did that how
have things changed for you since being
so public about it
events in my own life they really
encouraged me to like look more into
things about BPD and how I could help
people by talking about it more often
and making it more of like a regular
thing than something people look at and
are like oh you know
um in my personal life I think the
biggest thing that of that affected me
finally or influenced me finally being
able to grow is my dad my abuser
actually got killed
uh like four months ago he was found
dead in a car and I know that sounds
super selfish and sounds like
you know it's still a human life and I
totally do get that but
for me it pulled this like big weight
off my shoulders because I didn't have
to keep looking over my shoulder if that
makes sense like every day was not a oh
am I gonna get a call oh am I gonna get
is he gonna show up at my job or like
stuff like that and
at first it was really hard because I
wanted closure and that was like What
affected me is like I didn't get the
closure I needed but realizing that like
he's gone to wherever he needs to be a
better place is cool for me because then
I get to finally live my life while I'm
here and not have that like eating at
the back of my mind every day
um
another thing is
me and my fiance got a house just a
couple weeks ago and that's really cool
congratulations thank you and honestly I
would say the craziest thing about BPD
is it really affects relationships like
very it's very hard to trust and very
hard to
be able to love someone fully but
this person has changed my entire view
on it and I think finding your person is
a huge part of being able to heal and
like obviously the issues that people
have and mental health problems will
always be there but having a person
who's so understanding and doesn't make
you feel like you're crazy and that your
small problems are not
insignificant to them like that's a big
change and it helps a lot
um he I just spoke to him before we did
this talk and he really seems to get how
people with borderline will have really
high highs and really low lows yeah and
there's no middle ground yeah and he is
the most understanding person I've ever
met in my life like so loving so
understanding and that's helped me a lot
like just feel
myself I guess and not like question who
I am all the time or have such a
Negative sense of self
um because he he like takes it away
usually but he stabilizes you yeah yeah
that's nice it's starting to feel like I
have more Middle Ground days than like
you said High highs and low lows
but um
also I finally found medication that
works for me which obviously for
everybody medication is different and
you kind of have to it sucks but you
have to experiment a little bit and I
finally finally found what works for me
which is awesome
um obviously there's no cure
to borderline personality disorder but
having the right medication helps a lot
it helps you not have as many mood
swings
um
not have so many ups and downs during
the day as well just day to day so
that's nice
this is a nice changes since yeah since
last time I saw you yeah
um I feel a lot better as a whole and
obviously like every day there's still
little things but it's a lot easier for
sure and I've also learned that as you
get older it starts to get easier
because you learn how to like deal with
yourself
and that's something too is with my
boyfriend with my fiance he
he came up with this thing because I
always will tell him like I'll have my
little issues or like a little anxiety
or stuff like that and I'm like I'm so
sorry you have to deal with me and he'll
always be like it's not healing it's not
dealing it's healing and so we've come
up with that like it's not dealing with
you it's healing you and I think that's
super special too it's great yeah it's I
think just by sharing your story
you're helping create the understanding
of what it is to have borderline I think
that's very helpful for you and probably
for other people that yeah have Partners
or are going through this oh yeah 100
and addressing that too like
I also wanted to say thank you for all
the people who commented last time
positive things not only just like oh
you helped me or people who reached out
to me
um through social media because I was
able to give advice I was able to give
suggestions and help people with that
and I just want to say thank you for
broadening my horizons too because that
that helped me a lot
I also noticed last time that a lot of
people had noticed that you know there's
a trend in people with BPD where like
they'll be really really hateful and
really mean and like I just want to say
that a lot of people with BPD will not
own up to the things that they do and
that's I'm sorry for the people who've
experienced it because I know the bad
side of it I know how hard it is to deal
with people with that
issue because I deal with myself every
day but owning up to it and like
having acceptance of yourself is going
to make it a lot easier for when that
when a person with BPD wants to find a
partner and not make that partner feel
like they're living in hell every day
like it's it's really about
self-acceptance
and
I would say another big thing is talking
to a doctor is really important like for
a long time I was really scared and I
finally like reached out talked to
somebody before I actually filmed the
first video with you
um and that's what got me started on
like learning how to handle myself and
my emotions
and my issues which is super important
um on top of that I would say
definitely talking to somebody before
it's too late is also really important
because a lot of people are too scared
but making it
um more common instead of a taboo topic
is helpful helpful for people who want
to heal it really is
it's excellent
what would you say is the most helpful
piece of advice you can give to somebody
who's in a similar situation
um I would say if they're like if
they're struggling to talk to somebody
or like talk to a doctor or something
you say a therapist yeah a therapist
um like if they're if you're struggling
to get help or like struggling with
be part is to learn yourself and that's
really hard to do when you have a
personality disorder of any kind but
like learning yourself is super
important and like loving yourself I'm
sure there's a lot of people with BPD
they're undiagnosed oh for sure because
and usually they're misdiagnosed that's
another thing like misdiagnosed
diagnosis are huge
um because
usually people don't either they don't
speak out enough or the doctor's not
informed enough and once again like
making it not such a taboo topic would
bring knowledge to it so I think just
finding yourself and being able to speak
up is super important
and I would say I've noticed too like
now since my last video I can kind of
categorize like the different parts of
BPD and I used to think they were all
really really like bad and there was no
positives out of not positives but
easier things that come with it that are
not so negative
um I've noticed like for me the positive
Parts is I'm I'm pretty carefree and
I've learned that it used to be pretty
destructive like I would just be like I
don't care if I spend a bunch of money I
don't care you know but now it's more
Carefree of like I used to stress so
hard over the littlest things and just
get anxious and let it build up and then
I'd get angry and I've learned it's
easier just to let it go and now that
I've learned that it's crazy because
it's like one of my favorite things
about myself is like don't cry over
spilled milk you know it's so little
it's so insignificant and you can move
on from it that's like a big part of
something I've learned how long has it
been since you were diagnosed almost two
years two years so this is still fairly
new for you yeah it's definitely new to
me
um but I think the sooner you get it
diagnosed the better the more you can
learn about the actual disorder and
yourself too like learning about
yourself
was there anything else that you wanted
to yeah um I honestly just wanted to say
like there's a lot of things that are
common with people with BPD and it's
like the hardest things are usually like
the smallest things and they're very
internal and I've noticed that a lot
with myself like I hyper focus on things
and if I don't get them done I feel like
I've failed another thing I think is not
talked about enough is
body dysmorphia and a negative sense of
self
that's something I've struggled with and
I've noticed that with BPD it usually
leads to a lot more issues like body
dysmorphia anxiety ADHD OCD like it can
bring out those things bring them to
light and intensify them
and I think that's also something that
is not really talked about you know it's
like a spiral of different disorders
combined into one and it's it's tough
but they all seem to be related like OCD
borderline yeah yeah
yeah depression and anxiety yeah I I can
see that honestly and I I've learned too
that like
BPD is not I know that mental disorders
are inherited like they can be inherited
depending on the person and BPD is
caused by trauma so with that
um
obviously trauma causes a lot of things
and it's just always better to speak up
and get help and
my point of doing an update wanting to
do an update uh was just to like show
people that like in that short amount of
time you can get better you just have to
put in the effort and I loved all the
people reaching out to me and wanting
help because it shows me that like
people do want to take care of
themselves
and I think that it's just it's great to
be able thank you for having me here I
it's awesome thank you for helping us
all understand it yeah of course
all right Grace well thank you so much
for coming back yeah and good luck with
everything from here in your house
thanks